Julie Stout: Okay. Hmm.
Julie Stout: Okay, my name is Julie Stout, I'm here with Inta Carpenter. Today's date is February 25th, 2026, and we are located in Inta's home in Bloomington, Indiana.
Julie Stout: We are going to start our interview with just a little bit more information about yourself to see your background, your story, and just get to get more… to get to know more about you.
Julie Stout: To start with just some basic questions, can you tell me your preferred full name and pronunciation?
Julie Stout: My, my full name that I use is Inta…
Julie Stout: Gala, G-A-L-E, Carpenter. That was my maiden name.
Julie Stout: And what else?
Julie Stout: And pronunciation, if you'd like to specify that. Oh, INTA. INTA? Awesome. Okay.
Julie Stout: The next question is, how old are you today, and what is your date of birth? Today, I'm 81.
Julie Stout: I was born July 9, 1944.
Julie Stout: Where were you born?
Julie Stout: I was born in Latvia. I can give you the city as soon as I remember it. I was… only spent, you know, a little bit of time there.
Julie Stout: what was your childhood like? What were, like, what were your parents' professions? Do you have any siblings? Tell me a little bit about your family background. I was born in July… July 9th, and I left Latvia in about September that same year.
Julie Stout: I was 6 or 8 weeks old, I think. Oh, so you were a baby, essentially. I was a baby.
Julie Stout: my mother's… my… I don't know where to start. My father had been conscripted by the Germans into the army. The Germans had… had, occupied Latvia, so it was no longer free.
Julie Stout: And… So he was… In the Army.
Julie Stout: And my mother was living with her parents, and they lived on a farm in, baldwin, Latvia. B-A-L-D-O-N-E.
Julie Stout: And it was…
Julie Stout: they had… the war had started in Latvia, and it was… the house was bombed, and it burned.
Julie Stout: So, we… We had… we had packed, and we were ready to go.
Julie Stout: To do whatever we needed to do.
Julie Stout: And…
Julie Stout: we left… we left the house. My mother, as I'm told, this is all a story for me, she was in her,
Julie Stout: Bathrobe.
Julie Stout: And my mother… my grandmother and grandfather were with her, and they left.
Julie Stout: Pretty much, just with what they had on, because the house was burning.
Julie Stout: They had asked their 17-year-old son
Julie Stout: to go to the mill, I believe, to pick up some flour that they were gonna take with them when they left.
Julie Stout: the house.
Julie Stout: Whenever they left, they didn't expect to leave running.
Julie Stout: And he wasn't home. He didn't come back. And they didn't know where he was, but the Germans were…
Julie Stout: picking people up, they were coming… I don't know, they were driving around. I don't really know their story very well.
Julie Stout: So, they needed a ride somewhere, and they…
Julie Stout: in Riga, which is the city, the capital.
Julie Stout: And…
Julie Stout: So they got… they got in, and they… they went to Riga, and they figured that the son would… would find them there, because he would know where to go once he saw the house, that the farm was completely burned.
Julie Stout: So, they went there.
Julie Stout: And then they kept going, they kept going. They…
Julie Stout: they… again, I don't really know how that was all worked out, but I think that they had a friend who was someplace outside of Riga, because Riga was going to be… they found out, was gonna be attacked next, so they needed to get out of there. So they did,
Julie Stout: And…
Julie Stout: to make a longer story short, they did see my father one time. My mother saw him one time before we left Latvia, but then we went up to,
Julie Stout: to Benspils, which is a harbor.
Julie Stout: And we got on a boat there, and the boat took us to Germany.
Julie Stout: And… Ben…
Julie Stout: In Germany, for a while, it was still the war, and then… but not very long. Well, it was actually pretty long when you think about it, because it was about September when we left Latvia, and the war was over in March or May, or something like that. I don't fully remember.
Julie Stout: So…
Julie Stout: I think they worked, they worked. They… they… we were given shelter. I just know that my mother said it was straw. You could sleep on straw somewhere, and there were some kind of bugs that she didn't like that were there, too. That was her story about being in Germany at first.
Julie Stout: And I think my grandfather worked at, like, a sawmill or something like that. He was in his 50s. My mother was 24.
Julie Stout: I think.
Julie Stout: And then, once the war was over, then the United Nations created displaced persons refugee camps. They were called displaced persons camps at that time.
Julie Stout: And there's so much written about them. And we were in several of them, one after another. What the reason was for the one after another, I have no idea. But we were in them. And it was all the same ethnicity, so we were there with
Julie Stout: All Latvians.
Julie Stout: Which made it easier, you know, with the language. You didn't have to worry about it. I don't know that they spoke German, they might have, but I don't know.
Julie Stout: And we were there for 5 years.
Julie Stout: In Germany. So, I was 5 years old when I came here, and it was just 3 of us, but my…
Julie Stout: another… my uncle, one… my one uncle was also in the German army. He had also been… been… they just drafted them, because they were in charge, so they could do what they wanted. But they were still attacking Latvia, though?
Julie Stout: They were attacking, they were attacking, Russia coming in.
Julie Stout: I see. So the battle happened over our house, and then also started in Riga. I was wondering why they were… why you fled to Germany in particular.
Julie Stout: Well, because they got us away from the, Russians.
Julie Stout: And I don't know, I… I mean, the way they tell it, I was little, I was a baby, I laughed with them, I said, you blame the whole thing on me.
Julie Stout: And that they were… nobody could imagine that they wouldn't be able to come back. So it was just for safety, for my safety, if you will, that they left, and they thought they could be safer there than staying where the Russians are.
Julie Stout: gonna be in, because they had already occupied… they had… oh, that's probably an important piece of history. They came in in 1940 and occupied Latvia, the Russians did, the communists, and…
Julie Stout: They, in 1941 or so.
Julie Stout: Don't check the dates here. You know, you do check them, I think they're not going to be quite right.
Julie Stout: They deported something like 16,000 Latvians to Siberia, so nobody wanted to stay, because now it was 1944, so people knew what had happened.
Julie Stout: So they didn't want to stay in Latvia if the Russians were going to come in.
Julie Stout: So, we ended up in these camps, which… which were fine. That's where I started, kindergarten. I think I finished kindergarten there.
Julie Stout: In the camp. In the camp. Because the people who fled were the ones who were… who weren't the workers. They might have been more interested in the Russians and the communists coming in. They'd be more friendly to the ideology of it.
Julie Stout: So…
Julie Stout: You mentioned the, the 17-year-old son. Was that your brother? That was my uncle. Your uncle. Was he ever found? Was he… Yes, he was. He… he eventually… but my… the idea that my grandmother could leave without her son is just astounding to me, especially after I started having children. It's terrifying. Yeah.
Julie Stout: Yeah, we… eventually, he got… he… the way he tells his story is that he met up on the… going back home with the grain, he met up with a Russian soldier.
Julie Stout: And the Russian soldier said, what are you doing? Where are you going? And he said, oh, I have my papers right here, because he had been called also in. But this was in the communist armory, so there was my father working… fighting for the Germans, and my uncle fighting for the…
Julie Stout: Yeah. So that was what my family faced, you know? It's just pretty… pretty… so many did. It wasn't just my family, there were…
Julie Stout: Ultimately, I think about 80,000 people came to the United States.
Julie Stout: And others went to Australia and, and to,
Julie Stout: England, and stayed… some stayed in Germany a few…
Julie Stout: So they ended up all over the world, basically, after… after the communists came in.
Julie Stout: How many siblings did you have at that time? None. Zero. Zero siblings? Yeah. Okay. Yeah, my parents had just gotten married, and this was their first child. You were their first child? I see.
Julie Stout: So, my father stayed in Latvia,
Julie Stout: he had to, because by… by the time he got… the war was over, the Iron Curtain was… was down, and you didn't leave, and my uncle also stayed, so the family was… was divided. It was divided. So, your one question when you ask, where's home.
Julie Stout: As I grew up, it was both places, because I began to know Latvia very well, and meet family and meet friends, so home was here and there.
Julie Stout: So you were just here with your mom, essentially, and… And my grandparents. And your grandparents, because your dad and your uncle were still back in. Right. Gotcha. Right.
Julie Stout: And then we sponsored… the thing was that the United States had set up something where they sponsored you with a family. So we were assigned to a family in Shelby, North Carolina.
Julie Stout: that's where we went. We hit… we got to New York, and from New York, my parents say that… my mother says that she was given $5, each… each of them got $5, and were put on a train to go to Shelby, North Carolina. And there, the Lutheran Church has sponsored us, and so they had found a… they had found jobs.
Julie Stout: And they had found some place to live.
Julie Stout: Which I could show you a picture of that, it really… Yeah, I'd love to. …looks to me like a slave cabin. Oh my gosh! Oh my gosh. It really did. So you were in North Carolina first, was your first place that you lived in the U.S. Right, right.
Julie Stout: I remember that enough to,
Julie Stout: Because at that point, you were 5. I was 5, yeah. I started kindergarten there, again. Kindergarten again in North Carolina.
Julie Stout: Yeah, there was… there was… I don't know that there was water.
Julie Stout: there was… there was either no water or there was no heat. Probably there was no heat, because it was fairly warm in North Carolina, I'm not sure. But it… yeah.
Julie Stout: So they ended up with about 30 to 40 of these displaced persons, Latvians, in
Julie Stout: In Charlotte, in, Shelby. My son now lives in Charlotte, so we actually went down to visit, Shelby, and so we've kind of done a circle. A full circle moment. Yeah, a circle the family has to go back.
Julie Stout: And… So we had a community there. We got together. I've got pictures of… of us in our house.
Julie Stout: In Shelby.
Julie Stout: We finally did leave the shack, and… and my mother said… my mother was, you know, she was young, and she was educated, and she didn't like being treated like she was not educated, and she said that the…
Julie Stout: the woman who sponsored them, who owned a florist in Shelby, that thought we were rather uppity, you know, that we wanted our own house to live in. But they got together with another family and rented a house.
Julie Stout: And lived in that. And that's where I spent about 2 years. And then one of the families we had really befriended
Julie Stout: moved to Indianapolis, and my mother followed soon thereafter, so that's how we ended up in Indiana. So, about 7 years old you were in?
Julie Stout: Yeah, I started second grade in Indianapolis, yeah. Okay. Yeah. And my, grandfather got a job as a janitor in an apartment building on 9th and
Julie Stout: Pennsylvania, I believe, in Indianapolis downtown, so he had a… he had a good job, and there were American kids there that I got to know, and of course, the ones in school as well. Starting school in Shelby was tough, because I think I told you that story where,
Julie Stout: My mother takes me to school.
Julie Stout: And… There we are, and
Julie Stout: the teacher takes… gets the kids lined up to go to the bathroom, and we leave for the bathroom, and when we come back, there are no mothers anymore. And I don't speak English.
Julie Stout: So,
Julie Stout: It was traumatic. My mother said I didn't eat for about 6 weeks, but then I had learned the language, and… You learned the language in 6 weeks? That's what she said. Wow! Well, children can do that pretty quickly, you know? Yeah, their brains are able to pick up on it.
Julie Stout: Yeah, maybe it was 6 months, but I don't think so. I would have been pretty unhappy if it was that long, yeah. In second grade, too. It wasn't kindergarten. No, it's at,
Julie Stout: Oh, wait. Oh, no, no, that was in… that was in kindergarten. Kindergarten, you did pick it up, okay. Yeah, I went to first grade and kindergarten in Shelby, and then I moved… And then Indiana for second grade, yeah. Right, right.
Julie Stout: So where are we now?
Julie Stout: Where are we now? My grandmother got a job at… she was a wonderful cook, absolutely wonderful cook, and she got a job… What kind of food did she make? She made Latvian food, which is just, yeah, Latvian food, but she got a job in, the 500 race track.
Julie Stout: guy was… The Indy 500! The Indy 500, but he had a restaurant downtown that was very, very fancy, and my grandmother got a job there somehow, and… At the fancy restaurant? At the fancy restaurant, in the kitchen, in the kitchen. So it was perfect for her.
Julie Stout: And, my grandfather had worked in Shelby as a… in the… in the… in the florist,
Julie Stout: in the… in the greenhouses, and that worked because he'd been a farmer, and he knew all about that. That worked really well. My mother… my mother got a job in Shelby. Her first job in the United States was, like, in,
Julie Stout: A soda fountain place in a, in a,
Julie Stout: Drugstore? Oh, I can't remember the name of the drugstore in Shelby, but she got a job there with… and…
Julie Stout: feeding people at the counter, and she had… she had learned English. She… she could speak British English. Oh. And… but she couldn't understand the North Carolina English at all. The southern accent, was it? Yeah. Right, right. So…
Julie Stout: Anyway, we're in Indianapolis now.
Julie Stout: Do you have any, fond memories from your childhood, whether that be with your mom or your grandparents, or how would you describe your relationship with your mom and your grandparents?
Julie Stout: Maybe a tough question, but… No, with my grandmother, we would… we would walk… I remember walking in the camps, in the DP camps. She… she could find… she recognized, things like,
Julie Stout: She worked in the kitchen there, too, which really helped us. That apparently was where my mother washed me, in a… in a pot. I was washing the sink growing up. Yes, right.
Julie Stout: And, my grandmother would cook there, and so that gave us some food, I imagine.
Julie Stout: But she also would walk just to find wild, wild food.
Julie Stout: What do you… what would you call them? I don't know, but… Like, to forage and, like, to find stuff to eat, basically?
Julie Stout: And, and of course, mushrooms, too. She recognized the right ones that she could get.
Julie Stout: So, in Indianapolis, my mother got a job at the… you don't remember the A&P store. A&P store. A&P, it was where, in Bloomington, it was where the…
Julie Stout: Big Red is currently on the downtown area, the big one. The big one. That was the… that was the A&P grocery store. And she got a job there already in… in Shelby.
Julie Stout: And it was in the… In the butcher shop.
Julie Stout: And to the last day she died, she never would eat a hamburger that had been
Julie Stout: bought or offered in a grocery store. Does she really want fresh? She… she wanted to grind it herself. She said, you haven't… you haven't been there to see what's on the floor. Was it, you grew up eating the food that your mom made as well, then?
Julie Stout: Yeah, well, they both cooked a lot. They both cooked a lot? What was, like, your favorite dish that you had, that you can think of? Well, my… probably… as a child, my sweetest dish was… was rice.
Julie Stout: Milk, raisin.
Julie Stout: Butter.
Julie Stout: Sugar soup.
Julie Stout: That sounds good. It is good.
Julie Stout: just boil some rice. They were terrific cooks. My mother made
Julie Stout: I can show you that, too. She made cakes, that were like torts. They were really fancy, and… but they also made pea dog, which was a favorite of everybody, Americans included, which is,
Julie Stout: A kind of a…
Julie Stout: That shape, kind of like an egg, but bigger. And inside was, onion and ham and bacon.
Julie Stout: And it really is tasty. It's very good. There were other foods that… but mostly Latvian meals are sauerkraut, a lot of Polish kind of ideas, I think. German. German, really, it's German food.
Julie Stout: bread, dark… oh, good bread. It's, it's rye bread, it's really good.
Julie Stout: And meat and potatoes.
Julie Stout: So… I've got cookbooks.
Julie Stout: From them, but they didn't… they never needed any. Because they knew them all from making them all the time.
Julie Stout: So… so with my grandmother, it was walking in Germany, and then any time at home. She took care of me, basically. She retired fairly, fairly quickly. My mother was working, my grandfather retired earlier, he was 9 years older than my grandmother.
Julie Stout: So, they were… they were special people to me. I ended up writing my master's thesis about my grandfather. So,
Julie Stout: With his stories that he told, and jokes, and…
Julie Stout: And anecdotes, and songs, and things like that, and…
Julie Stout: About his village where he lived.
Julie Stout: If that isn't folklore, I don't know what is. Yeah, it was. And you lived it, too. So you… you were be… you are the best person to be writing about that, so…
Julie Stout: I think so. He really enjoyed it a lot, because we moved… we moved away from Indianapolis, and when we did that, he… I showed him how to use the recorder, and he used it, and he would send me things that he had remembered. He said, oh, last night when I couldn't sleep.
Julie Stout: I remembered.
Julie Stout: So he was able to record himself and everything, and give you that information. And he was virtually blind, so he was… this gave him really something to think about in his old age. Yeah. To remember positively, because he was… and he said, you mean my… this is going to be all over the United States? And actually, it's funny, because now it is. I can look on A Books, and there it is. There it is.
Julie Stout: He couldn't believe it.
Julie Stout: So…
Julie Stout: Oh, when did you move to, Bloomington, then? Or you said you moved away from Indianapolis. Is there some… where did you go after Indianapolis? I got married. I got married when I was 22, right after finishing college.
Julie Stout: And we moved out to Colorado.
Julie Stout: Where my husband had a job.
Julie Stout: In the steel industry, what he… that his family had been in. He was… he was American,
Julie Stout: I was not supposed to marry an American.
Julie Stout: And… Unfortunately, I had a beau who was Latvian, and the whole family loved him.
Julie Stout: Which made the American even harder.
Julie Stout: But we got married, and we had a very good life, and lived 50 years before he died.
Julie Stout: So, it was a good, good life. What was his name? Bruce. Bruce. Thomas Bruce.
Julie Stout: And how, how much, what was his age compared to yours?
Julie Stout: Like, was he older? Was he younger? He was two years older. 2 years older? Two and a half years old.
Julie Stout: We met on Friday the 13th.
Julie Stout: On a, yeah, blind date.
Julie Stout: I told you that one, I think. Yeah.
Julie Stout: So we went out to Colorado, and it was great. We weren't there very long.
Julie Stout: And then we came… then we came back to Bloomington, because he wanted to finish,
Julie Stout: master's degree, which ended up dragging into a PhD, but which he did not finish in the end, and he… that was in medieval English.
Julie Stout: And… We ended up with two kids born here in Bloomington.
Julie Stout: And we left…
Julie Stout: when they were little, when Amy was just a baby, and Alex must have been about 2 years old, and we moved down to,
Julie Stout: Kentucky.
Julie Stout: to…
Julie Stout: Cumberland. Cumberland, Kentucky, where there was an IV… there was a community college that Bruce got a job in.
Julie Stout: And we lived there for 2 years, and the saying down there was that if you come from the outside, as we did, and there were some friends we made who had come from Tennessee, from California, and other places, if you come from outside, you're going to be here one year because you're so confused, you don't know what to do, and the second year, you know you're leaving.
Julie Stout: And yet, even though, as I say that, we made so many friends. We just made so many friends in those two years. It was a very, very special place, very special place.
Julie Stout: Where in Kentucky? Cumberland, which, is… it's close to Harlan. Okay.
Julie Stout: And we ended up living in Lynch, which was the little community, the company town, really, for U.S. Steel. And everybody was pretty much working there.
Julie Stout: in the community was working for them. And they… they had nice houses, they had… they had boats, they had,
Julie Stout: RVs, they had… they were… they were doing good. They had plenty of money. We went back some years later, and it had all changed. It completely changed. Can you remember what year that was? That you moved to Kentucky? Yeah, it was 72 that we moved down there, and 74 we came back.
Julie Stout: the peak of the steel, like, era is in the 70s, so that makes perfect sense. And that's where I ended up writing my master's thesis, and in a…
Julie Stout: in what had been the office for the U.S. Steel Company. It was now empty, it wasn't really much of anything. Yeah. I could just go there.
Julie Stout: And we had so many, people to look after the kids. It was great. That's awesome. They also became friends, of course. So you built a community there, basically. What? You built a community there? Yes, yeah, we really did, and kept it when they visited in Bloomington as well, so…
Julie Stout: That's awesome. That's good.
Julie Stout: Building on your, like, you mentioned your master's thesis, after you finish your, like, elementary to high school, essentially, can you tell me more about your higher education? Like, where you went to college, what you studied, what you wanted to do for a career?
Julie Stout: In your aspirations in that? Well, it kind of connects, maybe I told you about this too, it connects to my childhood in the sense that, for some reason, I remember riding often in a car with my mother that would go through a neighborhood in Indianapolis that was fairly poverty-stricken, and
Julie Stout: Piss?
Julie Stout: So eagerly wanting to see in the windows, wanting to see what that life was like. And…
Julie Stout: So when I ended up in school, even though I thought I was going to study German, I can't believe why. I would have wanted to study German.
Julie Stout: But,
Julie Stout: I ended up in sociology, which is not that surprising, and I had an incredible teacher, wonderful, wonderful teacher.
Julie Stout: for all of us, I think we all really adored him, and he was a very good teacher, period. What was his name? I do not remember his name, but I do remember my high school teacher's name was Williams, and he was another wonderful teacher. Oh, that's awesome. He was. He's part of my…
Julie Stout: Passwords, Ms. Williams. But I don't remember the other one, unfortunately.
Julie Stout: He would teach in his house, you know, and he was just so easy and relaxed to be with, and taught us very well. And he didn't… he didn't mess with… he didn't mess with statistics or surveys.
Julie Stout: He taught us with novels, which was astounding to me, because that brought Williams together with his literature. He was my English teacher.
Julie Stout: With the sociology, and we read about various ethnic groups, and
Julie Stout: It was good. It was good. And so, when I got to…
Julie Stout: When I got to Colorado, I wanted to see if I could get a job in social work, and I did.
Julie Stout: And there was another community, you know, extended,
Julie Stout: there, because we were all young, we were all in our 20s, 30s, we knew very little about life. And,
Julie Stout: We were the caseworkers for foster children.
Julie Stout: And it was a… It was a very… it was a very deep sort of relationship.
Julie Stout: They came to see me when the kids were… when the kid was… first child was born, yeah.
Julie Stout: And so did… so did another one of them who had been in the Army and made sure to stop by in Bloomington, so…
Julie Stout: Those were… I wish I still was in touch, but I'm not.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Julie Stout: So then where are we? Oh, you mentioned, you got a job in social work. I got a job in social work, right. And…
Julie Stout: We came back to Bloomington, and only Bruce was working.
Julie Stout: And, I gave birth to my first son.
Julie Stout: And began to kind of be curious about school, and what in the world would… would I do if I went to school, and started thinking about that. And one day, Bruce came home from… from school himself, and he said, there's this department at IU called Folklore.
Julie Stout: And… I thought, well, that's interesting, because I had worked with Blacks, and I had worked with, Mexicans.
Julie Stout: And it… I thought, okay, well, we're going back to Colorado after Bruce finishes, and we'll… this would be good, so…
Julie Stout: That's when I went in and met Dawson, and had not yet been admitted. Can you tell me that story again? About that?
Julie Stout: Well, I waited all summer thinking, well, I'll get an admissions letter, or I'll get a rejection, one or the other, and I hadn't been over the department, I didn't really know anything about it. I know nothing other than what Bruce had told me. It's not like I was looking for it, and…
Julie Stout: So, when I didn't… didn't get admitted, and it was Labor Day, I thought, well, I better go and find out what's going on. So that, for the secretaries downstairs, sent me up to talk to Dr. Dawson, because he was… he was in town… in town that day, and in the department.
Julie Stout: So I walked in and told him that I had applied, but I hadn't gotten any response, and I wasn't sure what was going on and what I should do.
Julie Stout: And so, he… he did something to find out.
Julie Stout: what was going on, and I think he found my admissions form just somewhere, and came up with it, and basically said, you're… you're accepted.
Julie Stout: Right on the spot? Yeah. Yeah. What was your, I'm curious, what was your proposed, like, research topic in that?
Julie Stout: Or what, what did you want to study in the folklore department?
Julie Stout: that first day. Yeah, yeah. That first day, I just wanted to study ethnicity.
Julie Stout: I wanted to study ethnicity.
Julie Stout: And I don't… and there was… there was a Lithuanian displaced person who was teaching folklore. His name was Oinus.
Julie Stout: And so there… there was a connection to the Baltic as well.
Julie Stout: But I don't think I had any particular interest. I had ended up buying a bunch of the books that were… there was a series that Dawson had published on ethnicity.
Julie Stout: folklore in Mexico, folklore in Greece, and things like that, so I figured, well, this is… probably that was my focus, but I didn't have to say anything or declare anything. Yeah. So I just started taking classes.
Julie Stout: Don't ask me who the professors were. That's fine. Do you have any, favorite classes, or not favorite classes that you can remember? Oh, my favorite classes turned out to be in other departments. Really? Yeah.
Julie Stout: In Russian and East European with a fellow who just taught a really wonderful class in Camplit.
Julie Stout: In women's studies?
Julie Stout: And literature.
Julie Stout: So… Because I don't think that folklore stood out very well as teaching at that point.
Julie Stout: Who was there?
Julie Stout: It was a newer program of,
Julie Stout: Newer to some extent around that time, correct?
Julie Stout: I don't think so. No? Oh, newer, just period? Yeah, like, as an actual, like, program and department, because I know it was folded into other departments before then, but of course you probably remember better than me.
Julie Stout: It was part, part of the…
Julie Stout: Yeah, it was… it was part of English.
Julie Stout: was part of English, and then when Dorsen came, he created the folklore Department.
Julie Stout: We can talk about that now or later.
Julie Stout: Let's keep that for later.
Julie Stout: So that kind of leads me to my next batch of… Oh, well, let's finish one more thing, because then I went on for the PhD. Oh, yes, thank you. And that was only because
Julie Stout: I had by then been working for Dorsen. I had done the Gary project. This happened in the 80s, I think. And…
Julie Stout: Let's see… So I'd done these various jobs, and I think by then, Bye.
Julie Stout: Think doors.
Julie Stout: Why was it?
Julie Stout: Oh, I know, he asked me one time, he asked me to put together a CV.
Julie Stout: And…
Julie Stout: I hardly knew, I had no reason to know what a CV was. I'd had one job in my life, and…
Julie Stout: I didn't need a CV for it, I just walked in.
Julie Stout: And…
Julie Stout: So I did, and I realized that then, by then, I had seen some other CVs, and mine was, like, two lines or something. There was just nothing to report. And…
Julie Stout: And then… we started… we expanded from the Gary project to other grants and to other, projects.
Julie Stout: And along came Linda Dag, whom you might have heard about. Hungarian folklore. And she…
Julie Stout: had an idea, too, for a project that would… that would connect Hungary itself with Bloomington. And I became part of that.
Julie Stout: project, and… she said to me one time, she said, you know, you really need to get a PhD.
Julie Stout: And… and about that same time, in the 80s, mid-80s, late 80s,
Julie Stout: I thought, too, you know, this is… I don't like this. I really don't like this. I'm all constantly in a situation, in a context, where they're PhD people, and they're just different, and they seem different anyway. I better do it.
Julie Stout: So I did.
Julie Stout: And by then, I had… I had, since I had written my… my master's degree on my grandfather's life, the history of Latvia had… had come forth, and then also the history of the people who came here, moved here, came forth in the work that I was doing, and…
Julie Stout: So I realized that I would write the dissertation on being exile.
Julie Stout: And that's… that's what motivated it in the end, so that's how I got into Latvia. And a lot of field work and grants and so on to go to Latvia to do research.
Julie Stout: So I thank Linda Daig for that.
Julie Stout: She basically kind of, like, pushed you to do that.
Julie Stout: How did it feel going back to, like, the country that you were born in, but you don't remember that most of because of everything that happened, like, politically, militarily?
Julie Stout: What was that experience like for you? Well, you'd heard so much here. I mean, the community was so active. We had, you know, musicians who were playing, Latvian musicians playing, becoming trios, doing this, doing that. There were people who were writing books, there were theater productions in Indianapolis, so it was… it was a whole world of Latvia here, and because they had lost
Julie Stout: lost it in their eyes. They had lost it. They were exiles. They had… they were not immigrants. They hadn't done this on purpose.
Julie Stout: They were pretty fierce in their loyalty and… and their… their emotions about Latvia.
Julie Stout: So, going back there was… was a big deal. It was a big deal for my family as well as me, because they had not been back.
Julie Stout: In all those years. My uncle did visit us here in the United States, which was pretty amazing, really, since he got out. But he went back to his family.
Julie Stout: So, I went there with… with that kind of a… both a burden and a curiosity. And my father, of course, was in Latvia. So, I went the first time in 1983, before I turned 40. I… I just decided for myself I didn't want to be 40 and not have… You went the first time to Latvia?
Julie Stout: 19… I was… I was 39, so, it was 1983, I think. 1983. 1983. Oh, 39.
Julie Stout: At 39 years old?
Julie Stout: You said? Yeah. Okay.
Julie Stout: 39.
Julie Stout: So that was one big deal. I met my uncle… I'd already met my uncles, and I stayed at his house for 6 weeks, and I met my father, and
Julie Stout: So that was good, and then he had two children by then, so I had a half-brother and a half-sister. And when I arrived at the airport in Riga.
Julie Stout: I think some 35 people showed up to meet me.
Julie Stout: That's how the family had grown. Wow. Yeah.
Julie Stout: I'd met two of them.
Julie Stout: Two of those. A lot of, lot of people, some people my age, but most of the children were younger at that point. Just extended family, I'm guessing? Family friends?
Julie Stout: Yeah, extended family of 3 families. My mother had… my mother had remarried.
Julie Stout: here, and he had a wife and a daughter left there, and they had grown and married and had children. My father had a family, he had remarried, had kids, and, my mother.
Julie Stout: Had a family and kids, so there were plenty of people to meet. And I… one of the most… what I really remembered very brightly is just a tiny little incident, and that was little kids riding by me on… in bicycles and talking Latvian.
Julie Stout: And I couldn't believe it. They really… there really are people who talk Latvian. This is in Latvia. Yeah, this is in Latvia.
Julie Stout: There really are, because for me, I spoke English. I didn't really speak Latvian all that easily, or I didn't want to. Although, in high school, only Latvians were my friends. They were all my friends, and I didn't really make American friends, so that was kind of an odd period, too, but…
Julie Stout: But just to hear them actually speaking Latvian, so it's real. It brought back, like, memories for you, or just, like… No, just, just… It just kind of hit you? This was just an imagined, world, I think. It was really just an imagined world.
Julie Stout: You know, that was called Latvia. It really didn't mean all that much to me. It did… I knew it did to my family.
Julie Stout: So, makes sense.
Julie Stout: Did your mom move back to Latvia at some point, or did she say… She visited twice. Okay, she visited with you, I'm guessing, or…
Julie Stout: she… she visited… she and her husband went, and they went to his house, and his wife said to him, my, you've grown old. No, she said… he said that to her. He said that to her. I… I was… I was mad at him. I told him, you don't do that, little woman.
Julie Stout: In my, you've grown old.
Julie Stout: And with my father, he recognized him before my mother did. Really? Yes. He said, well, I think that that's Fred.
Julie Stout: They had… they had a good time, I think, and my father was a fairly amazing man. I… I really got to know him very, very, very well.
Julie Stout: In my 40-plus years. When you visited for the first time.
Julie Stout: Well, no, I mean over the years after that, over the years after that, because I was there very often, almost every other year, because I was working on field work for the dissertation, and then I'd made so many friends and relatives, friends, that I just kept going.
Julie Stout: And there was a time when I thought.
Julie Stout: could I live here? And I realized I couldn't… I was just about to ask you. Yeah, I couldn't. It was too small, even though it's about the size of Indiana, but it's too small, because everybody was Latvian, and there was no diversity, really, to speak of, and there was no rest of the United States, and Montana, and New York, and Maine, and so on, you know?
Julie Stout: So… When, do you still travel to Latvia?
Julie Stout: I… my…
Julie Stout: My husband fell in Latvia, and the result of that, 6 weeks later, was that he died. And so it's been very hard for me to go back, and yet I think… I was gonna go last year, and I chickened out. And, it's been 10 years now, so I think it's…
Julie Stout: It's…
Julie Stout: I kind of want to meet the relatives, and they came to visit me last… last February. Oh, did they really?
Julie Stout: About 5 of them. Three generations. Wow.
Julie Stout: 3… 3? Yeah. That's amazing. Yeah, it was great. Well, we've kept in touch, you know, it's been…
Julie Stout: We made friends, we really did. So I have a family, they're just very far away.
Julie Stout: I think that,
Julie Stout: Would you say that your life is a lot about, like, community building, and the friends and family you've been able to make in these different places that you've lived?
Julie Stout: You mentioned Kentucky, you had a really tight-knit community. You mentioned Latvia, you made some connections. Indianapolis, you had your Latvian, like, friends and everything.
Julie Stout: Did… do you feel that same sense of community in Colorado as well?
Julie Stout: Or… what was that like for you?
Julie Stout: It was great. By then, I pretty much was an American. I mean…
Julie Stout: I would visit Bruce's family in Ohio, and
Julie Stout: it was… it was fine, and again, we had… we had young people, and we had people that we went out with, and then, of course, Colorado's so beautiful, we bought a Jeep, and we… we just went out into the woods, and…
Julie Stout: Up the mountains, and we had special places we liked to go.
Julie Stout: And we didn't intend to not go back, but that kind of happens. Yeah, life takes over.
Julie Stout: Are you okay moving to the next section?
Julie Stout: Sure. There's gonna be some overlap, so answer as you will, but my next questions bleed into what we were just talking about, which is, like, more of your cultural background and everything.
Julie Stout: a basic one to just ask, just to get the ball rolling, would be what cultural and ethnic heritages do you identify with, and has your identification changed over time? I can guess what you might say, but I'm very curious to know if it's different. Well, it would… it would be Latvian, ultimately, yes. Right. Yes, absolutely. But then, my husband… my,
Julie Stout: My son married the Brazilian.
Julie Stout: And then I… I ended up…
Julie Stout: going to Brazil a lot. My first granddaughter was born… Really? …in 2000,
Julie Stout: And I was there within a month, And…
Julie Stout: kept going. Oh, she was born in Brazil. Oh, do they live in Brazil currently? No, they live… they live in the United States now. Okay. But, they… they did not then.
Julie Stout: And I don't even know what the… well, it doesn't matter, what they were going to do then.
Julie Stout: But one day, I got tired of the fact that… and I was studying Portuguese. I was studying Portuguese, but Portuguese is very difficult. It's a very difficult language. And I wasn't all that good at it. So…
Julie Stout: One day, I thought, hey, wait a minute, there are Latvians, there are definitely Latvians in Brazil.
Julie Stout: And I found them.
Julie Stout: There's a diaspora of a Latvian diasporic community. Well, there's some. There were some from the 1800s.
Julie Stout: From 1897, yeah. Wow. They did not speak Latvian anymore, but they remembered people or family members who had.
Julie Stout: They do the holidays of Latvia, they kind of celebrated them sort of like that.
Julie Stout: And then there were, 1922
Julie Stout: For… that's a too long story, but a bunch of,
Julie Stout: Baptist from Latvia showed up, and they had… Hadad,
Julie Stout: They had had some kind of visions that the world was going to come to an end, and everyone was going to shoot up to heaven. Oh. And so… and they had been told in Portuguese that that would happen in Brazil.
Julie Stout: So they… they had… they got in touch with that first generation of Latvians and got… found some land and moved to Brazil. And there's a… a village there now called Varpa, and I really got involved with that a lot, and it was… it was really fun.
Julie Stout: And they had… they had moved in there, and it had been a communal col… colony as well as an independent one. Wow.
Julie Stout: And then, in 1949, guess who else showed up? The displaced persons from Germany. So do you think it built that community even larger then? Yeah, even bigger.
Julie Stout: Even bigger.
Julie Stout: So…
Julie Stout: then that got me back there, because then there were grants and projects and so on to take me to Brazil.
Julie Stout: And, then there was one other group of Latvians that I'm struggling with right now, and that… in 2004, I think, I went to Siberia. And these were the people who had…
Julie Stout: Shown up there.
Julie Stout: In 1990s… in 1897.
Julie Stout: M.
Julie Stout: We were there only for 2 weeks, so now I'm trying to write up that, Bad experience.
Julie Stout: 4…
Julie Stout: a book, maybe, I'll get to it, that with all the things that I have published, but they're not in any kind of book, and they're not… they're too academic. I want to turn them into
Julie Stout: Real language.
Julie Stout: So those are my… my connections. I mean, so that gave me some… some experience with Russia, and…
Julie Stout: Of course, Russians have been part of my life in the sense of they're the enemies always, and here they weren't, because these Latvians described themselves happily enough as Siberian Latvians, although then they experienced it themselves as well.
Julie Stout: Is your research focused on finding
Julie Stout: like, finding these diasporas of the Latvian community in different places, or is it just so happens that places that you were connected to
Julie Stout: Whether it be your son or, like, other research, yeah? Exactly. Yeah. Exactly. That's so interesting. It just happened that way. It just so happened. Thanks to Linda Dag. Yeah, thank you, Linda Daig.
Julie Stout: That's so cool.
Julie Stout: You touched on this already a little bit already, but what languages or dialects were spoken at your home growing up, and what languages do you still use now in different settings?
Julie Stout: In different settings, that was the good part of that question, yeah. Well, we spoke only Latvian.
Julie Stout: If somebody called, and it was American, and my grandmother answered, she said, no speak English. No speak English. No speak English.
Julie Stout: So, you know, my friends, my Latin American friends knew that I was different.
Julie Stout: I didn't much like it, especially on a bus. I didn't like it to speak a different language, but I had to, so…
Julie Stout: And with the Latvian friends, we spoke only English, but we sang Latvian songs, and we danced Latvian dances, and we went to Latvian theaters, and were in them.
Julie Stout: And so on, so…
Julie Stout: You were in the feeder productions?
Julie Stout: I was not. I was not, but they were. Oh, but they were. They were brave. I was not so brave.
Julie Stout: I think I'm the same as you.
Julie Stout: you definitely already mentioned this, but your migration and movement story. You went into that already, but is there anything else you'd like to add to that? Or,
Julie Stout: How does it move your shape of home, and what home means to you?
Julie Stout: That might be a tough question.
Julie Stout: I don't know, sometimes I think I was… I was fairly confused by the whole thing. My mother, one time, went up to Indianapolis, apparently, and I do remember this moment of…
Julie Stout: she'd be… she would be… she was gone, like, 2 or 3 days or something, and I… I didn't know that the world was so big that my mother could just disappear. I just didn't understand that at all.
Julie Stout: And not come home, where was she?
Julie Stout: So, there was some confusion with the language, too.
Julie Stout: But, you know, kids… kids don't care in the end. In the end, the friends that I had first.
Julie Stout: I… they… I… they one time were all excited because they were going to have a hot dog party, and…
Julie Stout: Hot dog, to me, didn't sound so friendly or good. What in the world are they gonna do?
Julie Stout: So things like that happening, where you're just completely confused what's going on. You know, you've got this one world in the house where you're living, and another world out
Julie Stout: out beyond that. And of course, that's continued all my life. My grandmother, I don't think, ever forgave me for not marrying a Latvian, especially since I had what she thought was a very good one.
Julie Stout: So… And here you are. And here I am. Did she ever come around to Bruce, or… Oh, yeah, she did, she did, she did. She got on her first airplane when she was something in her, maybe 70 or something like that, to come out to Colorado to see us.
Julie Stout: And I thought she would be just frozen, scared, and on her way home, she was… she was just stuck to the, to the window, looking out the window. And she wouldn't… she just didn't want to get off. She said, what? It's over? I don't… I don't want to stay. She loved it that much. Wow!
Julie Stout: So she also kind of broke out of her shell a bit, too, with these new experiences. Yeah.
Julie Stout: So, I had a… I've had a very good life. There's no way around it. Yeah, yeah. I think when you have a strong support system as well, I think that really seems to be really influential to your story and everything.
Julie Stout: Okay, this one's kind of fun, because you mentioned a bit about food when I asked you earlier, but which traditions, celebrations, holidays, arts, or even just everyday practices, do you think are significant in your household growing up, or community?
Julie Stout: Well, yeah. I mean, Christmas had its own holiday traditions that were a little bit different, and I liked that. I mean, we would always go to church, even though the church was more interested
Julie Stout: In terms of the activities that it put on, to the… the history, that this was a country that
Julie Stout: Home is… someplace else. It wasn't… Latvians are not very religious. They're not particularly
Julie Stout: Yeah, they're not. My grandfather said we were always good pagans, and always will be good pagans. And, I mean, he's right about Latvians being pagans once, but I don't know, there are some that are very, very religious.
Julie Stout: But we would go to church, and so that all happened in Latvian.
Julie Stout: Music, that was… that was really wonderful, how much we sang. Latvians do like to sing.
Julie Stout: And… As do many people, of course, but they have their repertoire of songs that you learn.
Julie Stout: So, Latvian was definitely a part of it, and part of… oh, and Easter had… I don't think that… I think it had more traditions that… that would happen, and that children would look forward to than… well, Latin American children certainly look forward to Easter as well. What kind of traditions?
Julie Stout: Oh, there was one where…
Julie Stout: Well, the, the coloring of the eggs, it was done with, with,
Julie Stout: onions. Onion skins. Really? Onion skins, so it wasn't all red and green and yellow and all like that. It was all just…
Julie Stout: versions of brown, which sounds really boring, but it would get sort of also scratched and decorated that way, so that was different.
Julie Stout: Then there was one that sounds kind of silly, but I saw that they also were doing it in Siberia still, where you… you wake… you wake up
Julie Stout: And I had this done to me in Latvia, too, one time, by friends, where they come in with pussy willow branches, and they… they…
Julie Stout: whip you, so to speak. Wait, on the day of Easter, or… No, it was one of the days before. Oh, days before Easter? One of the days before, I don't remember which one, but… and there's a little song that goes along with it. What does it represent?
Julie Stout: It represents good, good health. Okay. Good health.
Julie Stout: Good health. I mean, it's very light. Okay, I was mentioning, like… No, it's not a whip. That's the wrong thing. Okay, okay. My grandmother would do it. She'd come out singing and doing this on whatever that… that… it was one of the Easter… Easter days.
Julie Stout: Yeah. Did you do that? Did you, continue any of these traditions, like, with your own family? And with your… Possibly Christmas, Christmas, and we did.
Julie Stout: Oh, you mentioned churches. Oh, there were… with the Christmas, the biggest tradition for Christmas, I think, that my kids would say was, burning, live candles.
Julie Stout: on the Christmas tree. And the Christmas tree was always a fir, I think it is, that's…
Julie Stout: very short.
Julie Stout: Leaves, or… not leaves.
Julie Stout: The branches have… yeah.
Julie Stout: The spiky… the spiky leaves? I think it has a fir tree. I think that's what a fir is.
Julie Stout: So, the candles are little. They're just, they're just little like this, and it's lovely. It's really lovely to see that, you know, 20 or 30 or 40 candles in a tree, you know. And it never burns it?
Julie Stout: Well, I managed to burn one. Oh my gosh, really? Yeah, in the condo. I would be so scared! Yeah, I managed to… we managed to set it on fire.
Julie Stout: Oh, we got, got it out.
Julie Stout: Do you, is your son… oh, does your daughter have any kids, or a family? Yeah, they each have two children, yeah. They both have. Are they continuing anything with their families, do you know of? Or… not the… not the burning candles? They remember… no. But they will remember it, though. Yeah, they remember it, and yes, but they don't…
Julie Stout: No. That's fair, yeah.
Julie Stout: Anything else you can think of for, like, everyday practices, anything else you'd like to mention?
Julie Stout: I don't know, that's one I really would have to think about, I think. Going to the theater was fun, always fun.
Julie Stout: In Latvian.
Julie Stout: with the Latvian theater, just the idea that there was such a thing.
Julie Stout: Some of the musicians were our friends, so they would be in the house, and you'd end up playing, again, Latvian music, and…
Julie Stout: Oh.
Julie Stout: Okay, and then I was too… I was too old to… to… I was already in college by the time the Latvians finished a summer camp up in Michigan. And,
Julie Stout: It was a school as well as a camp.
Julie Stout: And that was really nice to go to. I would go up there with friends when I was an adult.
Julie Stout: And we would stay up till 2 and 3 o'clock in the morning singing. You know, that was what… after the day… the day, it was… it was a camp for 3 generations, so you could go,
Julie Stout: your… to the grandparents, the grandparents, the parents, and the children, and they would learn
Julie Stout: Latvian stuff, and it was all in Latvian, so you had to be able to speak Latvian, but a bunch of my friends from Indianapolis who were younger, they learned really good Latvian. To this day, they speak good Latvian, and they're younger than I am, which doesn't make sense, but they learned it at that camp.
Julie Stout: And the people that would be invited were the main cultural people, so they were the best of the novelists, the best of the musicians, and so on, so they would teach
Julie Stout: Holdman.
Julie Stout: A kind of way to, like, continue spreading the culture, even though you're not in that country anymore. Yeah.
Julie Stout: So that… that was very special, and ultimately ended up helping one of my friends run that… run that a couple… two or three years.
Julie Stout: run it for this… for whenever the dates were for that, so that was seeing it from the inside out as well, but… Did you teach anything at the camp, or was it mostly, like, logistical? I saved a few papers there.
Julie Stout: That's nice. In Michigan.
Julie Stout: I'm guessing, is there a big Latvian community in Michigan as well? Would you say?
Julie Stout: Okay.
Julie Stout: So, anything else before I move on? No. Okay.
Julie Stout: So, you mentioned that Latvians aren't very religious, but you did mention going to church, like, for Christmas, and you celebrated Easter. And Easter. Any other religious or spiritual traditions that you grew up with, or that you continue to?
Julie Stout: Well, camp, but, you know, there were boys there. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And lifeguards. Yes.
Julie Stout: So…
Julie Stout: No. Not really? Okay. Well, no, there was one other thing. There was one other thing, and that was,
Julie Stout: Confirmation. That's a church thing, right? Yes, yes. And so that was sort of like our Mexican, when you're 15, you know, and you have a big celebration, and ours would be a big celebration. And you'd have… we wore white dresses, and we would, afterwards, we're greeted by all our friends with fresh flowers, and ended up with…
Julie Stout: like, a whole bunch of flowers, and then have a big party afterwards with gifts, and go from one house to another, depending on how many were being confirmed that particular year. So it's, like, in a town, basically? It was… this was in Indianapolis. Okay.
Julie Stout: So you'd end up with your age kids, you know, being confirmed, and then you'd party after. Were you, did you grow up Protestant, Catholic? Lutheran. Lutheran, okay. But there were Catholics, there were Catholic Latvians, and… and
Julie Stout: I never could understand what in the world that was all about. I just… I would say… I would say Latvians and Catholics, you know? I don't really hear… I didn't… they didn't fit. No.
Julie Stout: No, Mr.
Julie Stout: So, my next question is revolving around community again. That seems to be a huge theme in your life that I was able to kind of pick up on of when you were talking.
Julie Stout: Are there any other specific spaces that you found community in besides your school friends or the camp that you attended in Michigan?
Julie Stout: That had to do with… with Latvia? Actually, anything. Or community. Community in general. Oh, yeah. And however you'd like to prescribe community. Oh, definitely. I mean, what comes to mind immediately, the only reason we're really in
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Julie Stout: The primary reason we're in Bloomington is because
Julie Stout: somebody got in touch… well, actually, in part, Dawson, because we… we moved to Kentucky after I had started working for him, with editing projects, a couple of his books I was editing at the time.
Julie Stout: perhaps took with me to Kentucky, I don't remember.
Julie Stout: So we got down there, and I had this strong connection with folklore, and the students who had been here, who had been part of my group.
Julie Stout: to arrive.
Julie Stout: And one of them wanted to do field work in the area where we lived.
Julie Stout: And so, we ended up exchanging houses. He went down to Kentucky and just lived in our house for the summer, and we came up here and lived in his house for the summer. And part of… part of what he had at his house was a…
Julie Stout: was a parent cooperative daycare center that had been started called Hobbit House.
Julie Stout: And… We took his place.
Julie Stout: While he was gone, and that's where my then 3-year-old daughter went, and my 5-year-old son before he started kindergarten that following fall.
Julie Stout: And we each had shifts.
Julie Stout: They work mornings or afternoons, and we would take care of the kids, and smoke some pot, and so on.
Julie Stout: Crazy. Take care of them.
Julie Stout: And we really got to know each other very, very well, and it led to Bruce and me buying a log house way out in the country northwest of Bloomington.
Julie Stout: And… We would have parties there.
Julie Stout: big parties that were partly Latvian tradition, with bonfires and so on, for, for,
Julie Stout: June 20th, June 21st, Christmas, summer.
Julie Stout: And… the… folklore department people would come as well. We'd had to have as many as 9, as,
Julie Stout: 100 people out there. Oh my gosh. And… and then the… the Hobbit House people came, too, and they came one time
Julie Stout: years later, because we got a reunion going, and the kids had grown up, and it was really kind of fun to see them around the table in this log house, talking about what they remembered of being, you know, at Hobbit House.
Julie Stout: So that was definitely yet another. The house itself became a community, because people liked to come out there and be there, and
Julie Stout: Elliot Orrings looked after it one time when we were traveling, and so did other people. Would just look after it and then bring their friends. So yes, there was definitely…
Julie Stout: Definitely curiosity about us crazy people living out there. I can show you a picture of it. Yeah, I'd love to. Does Hobbit House still exist?
Julie Stout: It doesn't exist. It doesn't exist, okay. No, I don't think any of them do anymore. You know what we paid? We paid $17 a month.
Julie Stout: It was virtually nothing. Wow. Yeah. Wow.
Julie Stout: And I just ran into someone, too, at the YMCA, who had been there, yeah.
Julie Stout: a whole system built around this house, and to the point where you held gigantic parties with, like, folklore students, other people.
Julie Stout: Yeah, my parents would bring… my parents ended up moving out there when they retired. They… there was another farm on… for this… for sale, and they bought it, and then they… their friends from Indianapolis would come down, and we… we grew, we grew hay, and,
Julie Stout: some other vegetable. And we had… so we had a big wagon, and we had… we had pigs, and chickens, and… and, cattle, and…
Julie Stout: drugs, and cats, and the whole thing. And we also slaughtered them. People would come help us slaughter. So we were really doing the hippie thing for about 14 years. Yeah. Do you remember what time frame that is?
Julie Stout: Oh, yeah, it would have been 1974.
Julie Stout: 1974, 14 years more. We moved into town in about 1988. There you go. Something to a condominium. And that was when the condo… when you had the condo.
Julie Stout: So, I think, I think, yes, our life has been community. It really has been.
Julie Stout: That's just the way we've lived it.
Julie Stout: I think there's something about the fact that you were able to find commonalities with people, even if they weren't, like.
Julie Stout: like, only Latvian, that was your only connection. Right. You were able to farm those connections with people. Yeah. Yeah, and you know, the folklorist, too, helped. I mean, Bruce got involved. He was a compositor. He helped to put books together.
Julie Stout: And he worked with Henry Glassie for several years, and worked with some folklore journals as well. And he,
Julie Stout: he went to Turkey with… with Henry, actually. Really? Yeah, and then we… we brought… when… when Henry brought back a bunch of,
Julie Stout: Turkish artists to Bloomington. They ended up at our house and having a party, and it was pretty amazing, and there were Latvians, too, from Latvia there at the same time. Oh, really?
Julie Stout: So, when I think about that, you've… you've really… yeah.
Julie Stout: the connections. So it could be all kinds of people, in other words, and Hobbit House had folks from China, and from Japan, and Latin America, and so on. All over the world? Yeah. Yeah, whoever was studying at IU ended up in this place.
Julie Stout: In this, child Care Center.
Julie Stout: Just as, like, $17 a month. Yeah. Or $14, $17.
Julie Stout: How many, how many dollars a month again? 17. 17, yes.
Julie Stout: That's amazing for childcare.
Julie Stout: Anything else you'd like to add before then? Almost done.
Julie Stout: Okay, you mentioned before… Having some confusion with the Latvian language, and, figuring out…
Julie Stout: which languages to use with different, like, settings and everything. And that kind of leads me to my next question, which is, can you recall experiences of inclusion, exclusion, or, like, cultural exchange in Bloomington or elsewhere that shaped your perspective on, your story?
Julie Stout: No, because… and it's basically because I've got white skin. The only time that I might have been noticed as being different was when I didn't… when I spoke with an accent, you know, when I was 5 or 6.
Julie Stout: And once that was gone, the only accent I was accused of having once was Pittsburgh, because I went to college there, and I picked up on whatever the accent is in Pittsburgh. And,
Julie Stout: So, I don't… I don't think so. People are fascinated, and they'll… about the Latvians, almost inevitably, they'll end up saying, oh yeah, I went to school with one, and so that's not completely unknown to them.
Julie Stout: I think… I think that Latvian hurt me in the sense that
Julie Stout: in school, in the… when I was just learning the language, there was always that moment when it was the first day of school, and the teacher would say… would say, well, let's stand up now and introduce ourselves to each other. And so I'd stand up, and she'd say, well, what's your name? I said, it's Inta.
Julie Stout: What kind of name is that?
Julie Stout: Oh, it's Latvian. Where's that?
Julie Stout: So, I, to this day, don't like to speak in groups, before groups. I really don't like it. Because you don't like the questioning, or almost, like, accusing. I don't like the attention. I don't like the attention. So, I think that's where the one place where…
Julie Stout: I could never be a professor. That was actually going to be a follow-up question to me at the end, was, why you chose to do, your PhD and your research, but not choose academia.
Julie Stout: pure academia wrapped. For that reason, I'm pretty sure. Yeah. I'm pretty sure. It's part of your personality. I really like people, and my daughter will say, Mom, you'll… you find a way to talk to anybody. And,
Julie Stout: I don't… I don't have a problem talking to people, but not to get up like Dory Noyes is gonna do tonight. Oh, yes, at the talk tonight, yes.
Julie Stout: I'll do that. I mean, I've given conference papers and so on. It's, in a way, that's not a big deal, but… but to speak up, actually, the… the hard part is, like, we have a… I go to a…
Julie Stout: talk about not being a pagan. I go to a discussion group that my husband liked to go to, in…
Julie Stout: at St. Mark's, and it's gotten so big and so popular, because people are… people like it. We talk… we talk about all kinds of things, and sometimes just a good novel.
Julie Stout: But I don't want it to freak up anymore.
Julie Stout: I know these people. I just don't want to.
Julie Stout: then all these people are looking at me, and I don't like it. All the attention on you. Exactly. I definitely get that.
Julie Stout: what else do you talk about at these discussion groups? Because you did mention the books.
Julie Stout: Well, they, like, last Sunday, they talked about, National Christianity. Oh.
Julie Stout: Christian nationalism, and they turned… some… somebody has written an article and flipped it around and called it National Christianity, National Christianity, where in this country now, you can only divide,
Julie Stout: nations in terms of religion, so we can't be… if they're… if they're Lutherans in…
Julie Stout: someplace other than the United States, then that's a different Lutheranism. That people connect it too much to… I didn't really follow this very much. Interesting.
Julie Stout: So just, it's a different topic every week type thing that someone wants to bring? Well, or several weeks, I mean, several weeks. Or it can be something that's on YouTube, and somebody's speaking that we like, that we follow, who writes.
Julie Stout: I don't know if you know a woman named Ann Lamont. I don't think so. Who's a really… she's a wonderful writer, and she just writes short little books, and they're quite original, and sometimes religious, so… Okay.
Julie Stout: It fits, I guess. Forever a pagan.
Julie Stout: Okay, last question for this,
Julie Stout: In what ways has your cultural background influenced your approach to folklore, research, teaching, or the Dawson Geary Project? And I know you were helping out Dawson in that time, because you were kind of, like, his…
Julie Stout: Graduate assistant, if I'm correct, Eric?
Julie Stout: I started out as a graduate assistant, yeah, when that was with a book that I could remember if I would look it up. That's fair, yeah. And yeah. And then I continued it after the Gary project, before I got the job.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Julie Stout: Because I know that you… when you were back in Bloomington, and you were wondering, you were looking at school, thinking to yourself, what do I want to do, what do I want to study? You were drawn to folklore after Bruce mentioned it to you, correct?
Julie Stout: And then you did your master's thesis on your grandfather as well, so you're already kind of intrinsically tied to folklore in that sense, like, academically.
Julie Stout: And then you even did your thesis on being in exile, essentially. Being exiled from your home, like, your home.
Julie Stout: How do you think that continues to, like.
Julie Stout: change your approach to folklore today? Or how does it influence your approach to folklore today in your research? Well, I don't… I don't know that it did, because… because, you know, what really came to influence me in folklore was… was, that was kind of like my own thing about Latvia. I mean, if there was a student who was interested, and there were Lithuanian students that
Julie Stout: we… I could get involved with them in folklore, and they were Latvians. Ilza Akerberg, I don't know if you know her, but…
Julie Stout: She was here, is here still,
Julie Stout: But it did for the… for the public folklore, and the… the interest in applied folklore.
Julie Stout: That… that seemed to me missing. I think that I taught…
Julie Stout: John… John McDowell was, at one point,
Julie Stout: interested in that. The students, as I told you, were very interested in it, and we taught… we taught a class, I think.
Julie Stout: Together, so I did… and then I started… I st…
Julie Stout: a friend and I in Bloomington started up an applied folklore class here.
Julie Stout: That focused on the… a project.
Julie Stout: Over on the west side.
Julie Stout: The… the houses where people live who need help with… with money.
Julie Stout: I don't know if you've been there. I think so. And there's a… there's a Boy and Girls Club there.
Julie Stout: And we ended up with a couple of projects that they did, one of them with Joe LaMonteo, who's an artist in town, and he worked with them one year. He had collected a lot of bicycle parts.
Julie Stout: in a junkyard, and brought them in, and the… and together with the boy and girl clubs, they built this arch that went into the… the Boys and Girls Club building. And we… we did those kinds of things with… with, with the… with the people in town.
Julie Stout: We taught a field school one year that people applied to and came.
Julie Stout: I got involved with… with, Hmm.
Julie Stout: The one that builds homes. Not… not… Not Hobby House. Habitat for Humanity. Habitat for Humanity, that's right. I always get those two mixed up.
Julie Stout: So, and some of that transferred then to the students. We, we started, actually, we started some kind of meeting with Sandy Dalby and I, with students who were interested in talking about public folklore and applied folklore especially. So, I did do some teaching,
Julie Stout: over the years, for a few years, not too many. So that's…
Julie Stout: that's probably how I approached folklore, and then, then I began to work
Julie Stout: with reading grants for NEH and NEA, In Washington.
Julie Stout: And that led to their suggesting that maybe Indiana, you know, is… Indiana University is a little bit not involved in public folklore. And so that caught my attention.
Julie Stout: And out of that came Traditional Arts Indiana.
Julie Stout: So I feel in a way that that was my contribution, not anything from my ethnicity, yeah. Yeah.
Julie Stout: What do you… do you think that comes from your, social work background?
Julie Stout: I, you know, Dawson and I wrote an article about, public folklore, a joint article, and
Julie Stout: he was totally against it. I mean, totally, totally, totally against it. It was a big mistake, and I wrote the pro side about why
Julie Stout: So, folklore was… was, you know, a good place to… to think about, some kind of a…
Julie Stout: Public, possibly? He said that public folklore is just one big birthday party.
Julie Stout: What did he mean by that?
Julie Stout: That it doesn't… it just… the candles go out, and the party's over, and that's it, and I guess… I don't know.
Julie Stout: We'd have to read that article, I guess.
Julie Stout: So… But after, you know…
Julie Stout: I just think there was room for it, and plus, of course, there were no jobs, you know? The academic jobs
Julie Stout: petered out, and here was Bess Lomax Haas, was willing to… to… to think about helping the folklore people get jobs, and they got them all over the country, and they were good at what they did, and they… they then…
Julie Stout: Proceeded to make the thinking about it even better.
Julie Stout: and broader, and they had experience then. I didn't have any experience directly about it all. It was just an idea.
Julie Stout: That I always thought it was worth folklore in…
Julie Stout: Adjust, you know, putting in here, too, and along with the academics.
Julie Stout: So, I don't know, I think maybe now folklore possibly is… I don't know how it is with… with folk… with,
Julie Stout: Funding for public folklore jobs.
Julie Stout: I think I can tell you more later. I don't know.
Julie Stout: I've lost, you know, I've lost contact with all that kind of stuff. It's not…
Julie Stout: I know Barbara Hiller might have some interest in something like that.
Julie Stout: Barbara, John Kay, because he runs Traditional Arts Indiana, and Praveena Shukla and Jason Jackson have a museum background, and so not quite public folklore, but
Julie Stout: still aiming your research towards the public is kind of, like, their focus.
Julie Stout: And I think everyone else, to some extent, does realize that
Julie Stout: we are in a discipline that studies people and their expressive practices, you can't not address the people.
Julie Stout: I'd like to think that as well. Involve them too, yeah. Involve them in it. Invite them to it. And invite them.
Julie Stout: Is there anything else you'd like to add, either about your background, or a story you'd like to share, or anything that you'd like to address?
Julie Stout: I don't think so. No, you don't think so. I think we've used up more than your time. Oh, that's… yeah, no, it's actually… we're right on time, for what I alluded. Oh, yes. But the next time we, meet up, we're gonna touch more on the Gary project itself.
Julie Stout: And your experiences with that, if that works for you. Okay.
Julie Stout: We… it's about an hour 30 into it, and so I'm just going to stop.